[Music]
today we canceled jennifer lawrence
who's a hollywood actress been mostly
out of the spotlight since starring in a
series of flops over the last several
years now she's attempting to get back
into the spotlight again in the run-up
to the release of her latest film
and um having scrupulously studied other
hollywood actresses lawrence knows that
the best way to get the attention back
on yourself is of course to play the
victim card the fact that she has a net
worth of like 160 million dollars does
not at all hinder her in her access to
the victim card it's quite the opposite
effect as we will see in an interview
with vogue magazine
um lawrence runs through her list of
woes now
she begins with something that truly is
tragic and terrible and yet she manages
to find the least sympathetic possible
way to talk about it so
she says that she's suffered
miscarriages
miscarriages are an awful thing we've
been through that in my family as well
but then she quickly adds that she was
planning to abort the first miscarriage
anyway in fact she frames the whole
conversation
around the dobbs decision explaining
that the the recent birth of her first
child
somehow has um made her even more
steadfast in her support for abortion
she says quote i remember a million
times thinking about it while i was
pregnant thinking about the things that
were happening to my body and i had a
great pregnancy i had a very fortunate
pregnancy but every single second of my
life was difficult or rather different
and it would occur to me sometimes
what if i was forced to do this
now it's really hard to even fathom the
derangement in a statement like this
lawrence was pregnant with a child that
she said she wanted and yet took solace
in the fact that she had the option to
kill him
it's just the sort of thing that a
person should not feel comfortable
saying out loud but many such things are
said out loud in a culture devoid of
shame lawrence then goes on to attack
her own family speaking of being
shameless reading from the report and
variety it says according to vogue much
of lawrence's disappointment over roe v
wade began uh being overturned is quote
directed at certain relatives back in
louisville kentucky where she'd grown up
including her father the actor
had been trying to repair the family
rift after giving birth then the supreme
court ruling was made official and
complicated matters lawrence processed
her family drama in therapy quote i just
worked so hard in the last five years to
forgive my dad and my family and try to
understand it's different the
information they're getting is different
their life is different lawrence said
i've tried to get over it and i really
can't i just can't i'm sorry i'm just
unleashing but i can't f with people who
aren't political anymore you live in the
united states of america you have to be
political it's too dire politics are
killing people
she says i don't want to disparage my
family but i know that a lot of people
are in a similar position with their
families how could you raise a daughter
from birth and believe that she doesn't
deserve equality how
she doesn't want to disparage her family
but she will
this already tells you all you need to
know about this person i mean we don't
value loyalty very highly in this
culture mainly because we don't value
anything of value in this culture that
doesn't let lawrence off the hook i mean
if you will attack your own family in
public
over political disagreements of all
things
that tells us that you are a
self-absorbed backstabbing brat
well you know i have a lot of titles and
accolades to my name uh best-selling
lgbt children's author documentarian
biologist women's studies scholar you
know the whole list
but still i feel like i do not get all
the respect that i deserve and if you
feel the same way well established
titles is your opportunity to earn the
title of lord or lady and gain the
respect that you deserve in your life
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in scotland established titles
is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english so in your title pack
you'll be bestowed with at least one
square foot that's all you need of
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston scotland plus an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate features a unique plot
number um with which you can see the
exact location of your lead you can even
go visit it and just like stand on your
one square foot plot of land if you want
title packs from established titles are
a fun and unique gift for any occasion
and there are even couple packs that
come with adjoining plots of land for
the special someone in your life so with
your certificate you could officially
add the prefix of lord or lady to your
credit cards your plane tickets even
your dating profiles most importantly
and get this established titles told me
that the first 200 people purchasing a
title pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine so we can all stand on
our plots together in scotland i will
meet you there so depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or lady we
can build our own kingdom there
establish titles is actually running a
massive sale right now as well so if you
use the code walsh
you get an additional 10 off along with
all the other perks as well so go to
establishtitles.com
walsh to get your gifts now and help
support the channel
but she hasn't done she also reveals
that she has sought therapy
over over a recurring nightmare that she
has involving tucker carlson
and in the same interview she for some
reason confesses that she she had her
first political awakening moment by
watching 30 rock and finally
following the script of every
self-victimizing woman in hollywood the
filthy rich jennifer lawrence complains
about her salary obviously
she says inequality is something rather
this is reading from vogue again or
variety any inequality is something
lawrence has had to contend with in
hollywood too where she has often been
paid lower than her male co-stars
the sony hack revealed that she had she
made far less than the likes of her male
co-stars on american hustle while
reports reveal in 2021 that she earned 5
million less than leonardo dicaprio on
don't look up despite sharing top
billing with him lawrence told vogue
that all actors are often overpaid but
that doesn't make the pay gap any less
frustrating she added quote it doesn't
matter how much i do i'm still not going
to get paid as much as that guy because
of my vagina
well no jennifer it's not because of
your vagina it's because people are
more likely to see a movie for leonardo
dicaprio than for you
people will actually pay for a ticket
because they want to see dicaprio in a
film people will do that
i'm not sure anyone has ever purchased a
ticket just because they want to see
jennifer lawrence in a film and i think
she's a talented actress i just don't
think people are going to the movies to
see her
now technically her films have grossed
billions of dollars at the box office
but that's almost entirely due to hunger
games and x-men and those are both
franchises that would have had the same
success with literally anyone else in
her roles
that's the beauty of franchise films as
far as movie studios are concerned just
like plug anybody in and they'll make a
billion dollars
now we should also note that vogue
conducted this interview with her
uh first at an exclusive spa in santa
monica
and they had a follow-up at lawrence's
mansion in beverly hills so this is the
perfect picture
of modern victimhood you have a rich and
famous actress
lounging in her mansion wearing a
bathrobe which was what she was wearing
for the interview apparently while
complaining that she's oppressed by the
patriarchy because one of the top actors
in the business made a few million
dollars more than her on a film that
wasn't any good anyway
i think there is actually for the rest
of us though uh an important lesson in
this
now we know that spoiled and pampered
people like to claim victimhood for
themselves and we know they do this
partially to virtue signal partially for
political points
uh partially because it's simply an
internal reflex that they barely
understand themselves but
at a deeper level i think
the constant self-victimization of
extremely comfortable people who live
luxurious lives
only goes to show that hardship and
struggle
are really necessary components of a
full and healthy life
they're so necessary that when a person
is insulated from hardship
they begin to like desire it they want
it
they make almost a fetish out of it
a life of unending comfort seems
meaningless to them and so they
find ways of convincing themselves that
they're persecuted
and they do this of course without
actually sacrificing any of the comfort
because they could give up all the
comfort and then really experience the
margin but they don't want to do that
their commitment to suffering only goes
so far
but it does just go to show that that
perhaps real hardship is is not always
something to be avoided
because the people who succeed in
avoiding it entirely
only end up wishing that they still had
it
and then they end up embarrassing
themselves
as jennifer lawrence has done here
that's why she is today finally
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts